there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey y'all time for another episode of
the 13 o'clock podcast this is episode
169 yeah there's gonna be a good one I
think so this was a topic that was
recommended a very long time ago
this is Delphine LaLaurie yeah Ndola
Lauri mansion in New Orleans Louisiana
New Orleans case yeah is evidently some
slave owner and her boyfriend husband
her husband yeah we're torturing the
slaves for some reason might have been
some kind of medical experimentations I
don't know all the details but Jenny dug
up a bunch of stuff on it yeah the thing
about this case is that I mean I think
nowadays like I said this this was
recommended to us as a topic very long
time ago so we're finally getting around
to doing it I think nowadays people
probably know the name Delphine the Lori
because of American Horror Story I can't
remember what season it was it might
have been coven but they actually did do
like a fictionalized version of Delphine
LaLaurie played by Kathy Bates and you
know they kind of went a lot into like
the legend surrounding this woman the
thing about this woman that's that's
interesting to me and I think this is
the same thing that kind of interest me
about like countess Bathory is that you
know this woman undoubtedly did some
terrible things
you know she pretty provably did like
torture her slaves might have allegedly
murdered a couple of them for whatever
sick sadistic reasons of her own but in
the year since particularly since the
end of world war ii stories about her i
think have just gotten more and more
embellished and got more and more crazy
so we're like well yeah like with all of
these like more and more salacious
details being added like every time the
story is retold yeah and kind of happen
with countess Bathory's that's what i'm
saying this is a very similar kind of
case because it's a it's a kind of thing
where it almost it it kind of makes me
angry because you know madame milori and
you know and both Countess báthory like
I said it's pretty common it's you know
it's it's pretty well known that they
did do some horrible things but it's
almost kind of like oh well that wasn't
bad enough so now we have to like add
these other details like it's like well
this woman it's like the horrible things
that she did to her slaves and stuff
like that were terrible enough run and
it almost like belittles her victims
right to say that it wasn't bad enough
that we have to like add all these other
like crazy details on top of it a story
like this would sell it would even say
exactly to sell back in the 1800s yeah
and the best way to sell more copies of
whatever newspaper it is that you're
printing is to put more details in it
yeah so then these but you know how
we've gone over this many times about
how you cannot really trust
old-fashioned news you think there was
fake news now it was even worse back at
it back in the 1800s
straight-up yellow journalism the more
salacious you could write a story the
more copies it would sell so it
encouraged new it encouraged newspapers
to lie I think that big makes you does
well the interesting thing about this
story though is that the newspaper
reports from the time you know they
talked about what she had done and what
they discovered and stuff like that but
they weren't super exaggerated the
exaggerations seem to have stemmed from
about 1945 like a book of uh you know
Louisiana ghost stories or something
like that and the author of that book
seems to have added a lot of details
about her that that people remember to
this day and then people kind of picked
that up and ran with it to the point
where like I said you know they did a
fictionalized account of her on American
Horror Story it's like nowadays there's
like a so so when when did that those
books start coming out in 1945 1940
thank you so so many ways after she was
20 not sure she was dead and you think
about it it would be safe to lie about
it by that time yeah because all of her
because all the relatives were dead one
to back in the time this would have
happened
the newspapers would have been careful
with that with the story because they
wouldn't want a foster slave rebellions
yeah because that was a it was happening
a lot
time so yeah there was and I'll get into
that a little bit probably been more
more on the advantage of the local of
the local newspapers to stick to the
facts maybe even kind of minimize but
we'll see yeah it's gotta hear the
stories we'll try to get down the bottom
of them but yeah so this is like a
really really interesting story and like
I said there's you know still nowadays I
mean la Lauri Mansion is still there
it's on Royal Street in the French
Quarter and it's it's been renovated I
think it was first renovated in 1888 so
it doesn't look exactly the same as it
did when she lived in it um but it's
still there it's actually a private
residence so you can't go inside but I
think like pretty much every ghost tour
in New Orleans will take you past there
because it's one of the most famous like
haunted locations in all of New Orleans
even though you can't go inside but I
saw a couple of uh I saw a couple of
those ghost hunter type shows where they
just went in and interviewed people that
live there and people that worked there
and at various times and stuff like that
and they it's like nothing you know the
haunting quote-unquote hauntings that
take place there it's nothing super
egregious it's usually just like you
know weird noises and doors opening and
closing and [ __ ] like that
yes so we'll get into that in a little
bit before we do that we'll do our shout
outs like we usually do
we have a new patron this week named
Gareth so hey there thank you very much
for your support thank you also as I
said my short story collection
associated villanies is out an audio
book so if you want to check that out
you know you can eventually I'll get
around to doing hopeful monsters as well
but it's taking a long time because I'm
kind of busy with other things you know
obviously faceless villain 3 and all
that other stuff too I also wanted to
say that remember um because we we said
we were gonna like mention this a few
more times but if you guys like board
games card games stuff like that I've
designed a few that were kind of based
around Jolla movies
yeah they look really good um yeah so I
have a I have a site on um the game
crafter called giallo games and I think
there's three games on there now I'm
working on
another one but it's taken me a long
time to do because this other one that I
want to do is like a really really big
like board game and it's taken me just
to do it but I do have three different
games on there and an expansion pack for
one of them so I never mentioned that
and I need to make a commercial for in
show yeah I worked really hard on this
yeah another thing is I'd like to
mention is that we're getting to the
point now where we have so many
subscribers okay the show is already
being supported by a hardcore few people
on patreon yet I mean we have some of
our you know a lot of our patrons are
like twenty dollars a month that's
absolutely amazing and that is enough to
kind of keep the show rolling
but we're now at the point to where we
have so many subscribers and we get in
we get enough traffic to where if we had
a bunch of real small donations like one
or two dollars a month on patreon that
make a huge difference now yeah when we
first started this show we only had a
couple subscribers and a few patrons
yeah you know I'm only making a couple
hundred bucks a month well now what are
we up to now in terms of hardcore
patrons maybe about three four dollars a
month something like that yeah 400 ton
Sephora and some which you know that's
not much but that's enough you know what
I mean to make it worth doing the show
we really you know we should when we
started the show we really just we're
gonna use it to run ads for her books
yeah we really consider patreon at the
time but now we're almost pushing 8,000
subscribers if even just 10% of our
people gave us a dollar a month it'd
make a big difference yeah
so you know just like you guys to
consider it if you want us given us a
small monthly donation on patreon that
now would make a big difference yeah and
you know like I said all of our patrons
all of our people that send us donations
through PayPal and like I said you know
one of our one of our listeners Ben sent
me a computer which was super awesome I
just now got finally got it set up
because I had a lot of stuff I had a
transfer over and we got the meat and
potatoes covered but maybe some gravy be
nice
and for our big subscribers you know
every quarter we sent out uh some custom
shirts and we got some good ideas for
some cool shirts gonna probably a movie
based movie mashup between 13 o'clock of
movies yeah I was gonna do like a 13
o'clock and crustle shirt and [ __ ]
you know I mean maybe 13 o'clock in the
shining
combined that's the first one I was
thinking yeah we might do something we
need to do that soon because I think we
forgot to do it last quarter because it
took us so long to get the ones from
June out because we started making them
yeah and then it took us so long to get
the screens right and all that other
kind of stuff so I think I think mid
December will probably think about yeah
I've got a lot better at doing it too
and also to do all the purchasing for it
this source and all those shirts all
those black shirts can get rough yeah
because it's it really doesn't make it
Emily I'll clean Walmart out
yeah because usually what we were going
to do Oh cookies play with the camera on
the tripod geez can't help herself
but yeah so um it's almost like not
worth it to order like wholesale online
just because usually that has like a
minimum like you usually have to get a
hundred minimum or 200 minimum we don't
need that many we usually just need like
40 or 50 or 50 right so yeah usually
what we do is go to Walmart or Michaels
or something like that and yeah they
have good quality cotton shirts or them
or the blends yeah - the lightweight
blends I like those because they don't
ever fade yeah and in hot weather during
the summer they're comfortable but those
100% cotton once we get out of Michael
they're nice yeah nice the only thing I
don't like about now - I could clean
Michaels out in a single visit though
yeah usually they'll only have like 10
of each size that's true although no
because they have that whole um they had
that whole aisle of all different ones
they it's like that but sometimes you
have to watch because sometimes they
don't have like the women's fitted ones
you know I mean you just gotta like what
we can work it out we can work it out we
it depends on when you don't get
supplied we only have to do about 50 of
them every that's what I mean it's not
like you know I can always let him
restock and go back there and do it
again go by and go hear them again yeah
or we could drive farther away to
another Michaels I'm sure there's
another Michaels like not that far away
all right so let's talk a little bit
about Delphine LaLaurie yeah now as I
said nowadays she's kind of remembered I
you know that she called a monster
called the serial killer you know called
various other things and like I said
what she did was bad enough even though
they didn't they didn't really catch her
until 1834 well they never caught her
but they didn't really know what she was
up to until like 1834 when it was a fire
at the house and they all went in there
to see what was going on but it just
seems like prior to that there wasn't
really any inkling that she was doing
anything wrong it really wasn't until
she married her third husband so I don't
know if he had something to do with it
or if she just snapped because of
something he did or something like that
because she'd been married before and
she lived in society for quite a long
time and like no one had really you know
there were no like salacious rumors
about her pretty much until she like
married her third husband how old was he
she more or less by that time uh I don't
really know how about his forties yeah I
think she was in her 40s or 50s she was
born around 1775 okay and actually her
parents were pretty like high up like
wealthy aristocrats very high up in the
white Creole community of New Orleans
they were Irish French I believe her
grandfather was the one that had moved
from Ireland and like settled them in
New Orleans so so like I said this is a
very prominent family I believe one of
her cousins was actually a mayor of New
Orleans for five years 1815 to 1820 so
she was actually born Delphine McCarty
or McCarthy
yeah and during the time was she lived
in New Orleans was already old yeah I
mean the Spanish had it for you know
thinking back of the 1500 Zeus right I
think I believe it was still under
Spanish rule dry tyrone this town is
like what lore when her family first got
there yes Spanish had it then the French
had it and
maybe he went back to Spain and then
later on it got purchased by the United
States during the Louisiana Purchase
but still you know through most of its
history you might even be able to say up
until today
New Orleans is like a pirate city it
it's always kind of existed in its own
parallel universe
yeah semi criminal really even the cops
you know the to this day a NOPD and bad
reputation you know you kind of I have a
lot of experience [ __ ] around down
there in that French Quarter route
Decatur Street okay you want to steer
clear of [ __ ] New Orleans French
Quarter you know and the front it French
Quarter is actually safer than a lot of
other places in the New Orleans now
after Katrina maybe it's changed but
Africa Trina you know haven't been there
you know since then but you know post
Katrina or pre Katrina excuse me it was
bad today and I think it was always bad
well as a glamorized dim it's done
particularly because of like and rice
and pop easy bright - oh yeah that's our
extent that's not the way it really is
yeah that's not the way it really is you
know who kind of called it that damn
Sylvester Stallone movie bullet to the
head it's taking place in New Orleans
that's really what it's like yeah yeah
it kind of feels more like a dirty
version in New York you have a lot of
people with New York accents and a lot
of them are from there you know you have
a lot of New York Italians and just it's
not really a great place really you know
to me not an organized crime I do feel
like though that that happens a lot not
just with New Orleans it happened with
New York in the 70s it happened with
Chicago and all the mob and everything
like that worries even though it's
terrible and you probably wouldn't want
to live there in real life it's like
people still have this kind of glamorous
yeah image of it like they want to see
movies about it or so there's something
very romantic about it I guess yeah it's
like a [ __ ] up way it's like a dirtier
lower budget smaller version of Las
Vegas but nothing's legal yeah [ __ ]
that's going on there's Ely
a lot of it yeah yeah but illegal but
tolerated in a weird way yeah so alright
so Delphine's family like I said we're
very wealthy and had been in New Orleans
for about three generations now in 1800
when Delphine was about 14 or 15 years
old she was married off to her first
husband whose name was Don ramón de
Lopez II and Gullo who was kind of a
high-ranking Spanish officer now by 1804
he actually kind of got a promotion I
guess and became like the Consul General
for Spain in Louisiana
now also sometime in 1804 Delphine and
her husband went to Spain on a voyage
they're not entirely sure why there's a
couple of different reasons it doesn't
really matter I guess but they're you
know they they go on of like a voyage to
Spain during the trip I don't know if it
was on the way over or on the way back
Delphine had a daughter you know so she
had a baby on the boat now also sometime
around this time and like I said I'm not
real clear on whether it happened in
Spain or would that happen on the ship
or something like that the first husband
died I don't think there was anything
like sketchy about it or anything like
that I think he just had a heart attack
or whatever so that was her first
husband down so about four years later
1808 she marries her second husband
whose name is Jean Blanc he was also he
was a kind of a wealthy dude he was a
banker a lawyer
also he was in a law like he was a
legislator he was in law or whatever now
during this time of her second marriage
this was when they bought a house on
Royal Street this was number 409 so this
is not this isn't the house that like
later became famous but it's on the same
street so yeah this was called the via
Blanc or the Villa Blanca or whatever
now with her second husband she had four
more kids now this husband also died in
1816 and after this happened it seems
like that Delphine was like single for
about ten years at this point she was a
widow
now she had money of her own like I said
her her family was very prominent of she
owned property in her own name she had
her own money so I guess she wasn't
really worried about you know hitching
the wagon to like some other dude or
whatever so she's single for ten years
and then she marries her third husband
whose name was Leonard La Lori and this
is where she gets her most famous name
from now he was a lot younger than her I
believe she was at the time she might
have been 38 or she might have been in
her early 40s maybe and he was only 25
now he was a doctor um I saw one I saw
one thing as I watched a bunch of
documentaries about this I saw one thing
that said he was a doctor but he had
graduated like last in his class or
something but he's like still a doctor
doesn't matter if you laughs in your
classroom yeah doctor back then wasn't
saying much true that's what I mean it's
it yes it sounds like a big deal now
somebody's a doctor cuz you have to like
good one step above barber pretty much I
mean yeah and sometimes glorified barber
yeah yeah yes so he was only 25 years
old like I said and he as far as I know
he didn't have a [ __ ] ton of money I saw
like a one source that said he came with
a you know with them a fortune of like
only two thousand dollars unlike that
which you know was a lot of money back
then obviously but I think not only was
she a lot older than him and more
prominent than him but you know she was
also a lot wealthier than he was so I
you know I don't know what the whole
situation was now I'm laughing at
doctors back in the olden days using the
dividing line between doctor and non
doctor was that a doctor could perform a
nap amputation yeah that was the main
difference they can amputate a damn limb
that's proud I'll probably just like a
cleaver and they travel bounce off yeah
both eyes and then they didn't make a
flap and sew it together and you know
put a tourniquet on and then amputate
and if you actually saw the procedure
the training manuals anybody could do it
really well yeah how's he having balls
just like not having the gusset doing
not be fricative like yeah bunch other
dudes wedding another guy down why
scream and sawing off damp
arm or a bad leg yeah and that's you
know no aunt there was no antibiotics
back then you just well you hopefully
you'll be alright here have some whiskey
yeah or here's like a big leather thing
that yeah but your mouth fits you want
people are tough man they survived it
well Nate what's worst it's probably
better than dying yeah no anesthesia or
anything yeah I know
I don't know thank you sometime they had
it but they just usually were out of it
yeah you know it existed it's just that
battlefield battlefield doctors you know
usually they ran out of that [ __ ] quit
well yeah I imagine they probably would
have people coming through there all the
time yeah so shortly after she marries
her third husband they buy the very
famous property at 1 1 400 Royal Street
which as I said still stands there today
and is the house that you will see on
the ghost tour if you get in New Orleans
to take one of the ghost tours as the LA
Laurie mansion now this was in 1831 now
she actually bought it I don't know if
her husband's name was on the mortgage
or just hers was but she like managed
the house pretty much all by herself it
was mostly her money like I said cuz he
wasn't super rich or anything so by 1832
they had put this the three-story
mansion there so she lives there with
him and two daughters and they also had
slave quarters obviously like a lot of
people in high society did then and she
kind of um like I said she was a
prominent member of society show so she
was kind of like well known in high up
particularly the Creole circles and she
was also well known for giving like
really lavish parties for being like a
really good party hostess and you know
having all that type of stuff going on
and as I said prior to her marrying this
guy
there there wasn't I I read somewhere
that they said there just wasn't like
any whiff of any impropriety on her part
no rumors swirling about her nothing
like before she married this guy but
then after they after they got married
and after this they had this house built
[ __ ] started to change so they have a
bunch of slaves in their household
sources differ I've heard that they had
up to 26 which was actually kind of a
lot for a house that size I think
average they usually had about from
between six or eight like in a household
of that that size now even prior to the
fire
the very famous fire that happened in
1834 people started the rumor started
circulating among society circles that
she was unusually cruel toward her
slaves now it's it's funny because like
so many it's not funny but it's like you
know so many prominent families owned
slaves at the time that you would think
why would it be a big deal that she was
like mistreating them or so like that
but there were actually laws about how
to treat your slaves yeah New Orleans
there were also a lot of a whole culture
behind it too you don't I mean some of
the stuff that you see in movies or you
see in Maya is not really you know the
way they show slavery that's not really
what you would find on the average it
was there was a spectrum you had I mean
Silas plantations were bad places all
the ones were not so bad you know but
you're dealing with another time you're
dealing with a time when human life
didn't really have the same value it had
now you know and people didn't live long
and education wasn't that good even the
very educated people weren't that well
educated by today's standards and then
just the whole cultural value system was
different but in general when it came to
plantation owners and slaveholders in
general the idea was almost kind of
almost like a damn pimp culture in a way
where the plantation owner was supposed
to be like the king of his own domain
and his status came from how great and
how rich his plantation was and he
evidently got a lot of bonus points if
his slaves were dressed in finery and
retreated well that didn't always happen
but those were the guys at the top that
was part of showing off their well
and power according to this culture and
it was this plantation culture culture
basically a cracker culture really to
mistreat slaves would be considered kind
of backwards and stupid and wrong they
wouldn't they wouldn't like that now
they did punish slaves for what they you
know with crimes or for breaking rules
you know I mean but so did the army so
did the Navy you know but sometimes they
would get kind of brutal you know they'd
hobble people you know it was a brutal
time you know you can't really apologize
for it you just have to take it for what
life was like and what the thinking was
like of those times so yeah if you
mistreated slaves other slaveholders
would by the rules of their culture
they're supposed to consider you to be a
piece of [ __ ] if he did that yeah and
that's why like I said um you know
obviously slavery was legal but you were
allowed and this was I'm not sure like
I'm just because I'm sure the law is
different from like stator 1/2 or County
to County to County in this particular
area in this part of Louisiana the law
was you were allowed to keep slaves in
Chains or irons you know to keep them
from going anywhere you were allowed to
whip them or flog them with whips
leather thongs ropes rods you could do
that but anything other than that like
you weren't really allowed to mutilate
them or like cut their limbs off or
anything else which is terrible to say
but that's was codified into the law
that's what it said you couldn't
arbitrarily execute him either
yeah they they had to committed some
kind of a crime and some and found
guilty but like I said you're talking
about a time where things were not
highly organized and it was different
from County to County
like for instance even Mississippi alone
Mississippi was considered to be a slave
state but there were counties inside of
Mississippi they had bandit you know and
it's the the county the free state of
jail ones that's where Jones Jones
County Mississippi where my family's
from was called the free state of Jones
it was it was a it was slavery was
banned there yeah that's what all this
slave caching was about a lot of times
this runaway slaves weren't running to
another state they're running to another
County yeah so there was a nothing made
sense during that time civilization was
still kind of forming you had situations
where states were spent a lot of time
trying to figure out how to saw how to
how to actually solve problems that are
happening between counties within the
own state you know I mean yeah you'd
have a County saying banning slavery in
another County saying well we have
slavery we have to ban that County from
banning slavery in other words reverse
the band right there so it was you
dealing with a gregarious is within a
Gregorian society and it was kind of a
lot like feudal Japan with daimyo and
fiefdom Xand yet oh yeah it wasn't
uniform it was not really you know it
wasn't it wasn't unified under a
Shogunate like Japan eventually became
you know unified it didn't the South
didn't really become unified until after
the Civil War during construction and
even that really didn't happen all that
well you know I mean because he had
dream crow type stuff going on for a
long time well yeah up until [ __ ] the
sixties yeah I would say it was not
until maybe the 80s the city I got there
and and really from my memory of it what
unified the south and changed the South
was actually MTV and cable television
well it does have kind of a
democratizing influence because everyone
was seeing the same stuff all saw the
same stuff they were all aspiring to the
same culture yeah when you see Duran
Duran okay and then you see prints you
know and then you see Michael Jackson is
start becoming part of a larger national
culture over time you know to me and
just things change yeah you couldn't you
didn't have local Baptist churches
telling you what culture was you could
now go on television and see what
culture was yeah
so that that's really what did it and
particularly like the younger people of
the time yeah all kind of like just
plugging all into this type of stuff and
kind of getting more into the youth
culture that yeah yeah from my was kind
of rejecting from my general old people
my generation everybody in my generation
that that I knew growing up in
Mississippi or going to some Mississippi
every summer they're not there anymore
yeah they moved out of that state they
just I just have to do yeah yeah it's a
big world out there yeah but yeah so
basically like I said there were laws on
the books that not to protect slaves
necessarily but just you weren't a
regulated it was regulated and as you
said there had been many slave revolts
or some in Haiti there was actually one
in New Orleans in 1811 so people were
kind of paranoid about mistreating their
slaves because some people you know some
masters had been killed by their slaves
you know fighting back against them for
their cruelty you had [ __ ] yeah you
know and you had mistreatment of people
all people slaves and slaves were people
at the bottom of the system which would
have been then well I wouldn't say the
slaves are at the total bottom maybe
legally they were but I think probably
the ones that were probably poorer than
them would have been some of them
sharecroppers you had I mean and Irish
yeah the Irish were slaves to you know
basically but they worked their way out
of it but yeah slavery was bad yeah yeah
I don't think you'll have anybody argue
is that sentiment yeah it had to have
regulations to keep slave owners under
some means of control you know well and
this is a horrible there's a horrible
thing to say but also you know that
slave was considered property yeah and
as such it could be purchased by another
person so I think there was also an
aspect of not damaging property in case
someone
got a lot of it had to do with the
psychology of the time yeah you couldn't
really get somebody to work for it they
tried this this goes all the way back to
ancient Greece you know where we're
Greeks were enslaving captured soldiers
and taking them back to their own city
to have them rebuild the city you know
mean they weren't an agricultural slave
for the most part and their slavery was
usually like a term of about twelve
years then they had been they could go
back home and then you had slavery
during the Roman times all right and
during that time this is all part of
Western civilization during that time
they learned a lot about slave
management how to prevent uprisings you
know you can't really long-term get work
out of people by beating it out of them
yeah yeah givethe Lee and you have to
give them rewards and that's what the
Romans did and you rewarded slaves he
gave them better and better positions
within the household now eventually the
Romans figured that if you that if you
were related to your slaves they
wouldn't revolt at all and that started
to go on also in the south is it because
they were crossbreeding with them yeah
and you put your sons or your cousins or
your nephews your half-black nephews in
charge of certain functions of the
plantation and you wouldn't have
rebellions you know that happened a lot
yeah I sent him to France and having
trained his cooks and then bring them
back under pseudonyms so and then say
that they were from France there was a
bunch of different ways to get him out
from underneath that system or to get
that system to work for you so they had
it all down to a science really but it
like I said it was piecemeal their books
were all books written about it in
letters that survived some plantations
were better than others yes I mean just
like all of them were [ __ ] bad really
bad you know I mean they were broke and
they were beaten the slaves and slaves
were dying
I saved your running from it and shut
like that and other ones were more kind
of as it's like a work camp yeah you
know you wouldn't want to be a slave
well yeah like I said nobody would
really think any nobody would choose it
no of course not no but yeah so it seems
to be that as I said once Delphine and
her husband had moved to this particular
house on Royal Street and had their
slaves in their household that they were
maintaining it seemed like rumors
started to swirl about her mistreatment
of them which like I said was egregious
even for the time yeah so the stories
kind of started to come out right around
1831 that you know other people who
lived around town or like moved in those
same circles said that her slaves looked
unusually thin as though she'd been
starving them that they looked very
Haggard and wretched quote-unquote you
like I said more unusually than other
people's slaves like they looked really
bad they looked really tired or sick and
things like that but then again there
were other accounts that you know when
she was out in public she seemed very
nice toward toward African Americans in
general because there's some of them not
all of them were slaves obviously some
of them were were free and that she was
very polite to them in public that
doesn't necessarily mean that she wasn't
a horrible person to them in private
which seems to be the case but there's
kind of a thing where you know I was I
was reading this one thing on like a
kind of a historical website about like
maybe all of the reasons why she was
acting in this particular way you know
when they're like well did she have some
kind of particular hatred for slaves or
did she have some kind of particular
hatred for black people or something
like that but it seems like
contradictory because she did seem to
treat some of her slaves well you know
what I mean I mean the thing is okay now
her uncle now before she was born
like shortly before she was born her
uncle was killed by one of his slaves in
1771 so she would have known about that
because it was family lore two of her
cousins were killed in the New Orleans
slave revolt in 1811 so some people have
speculated that maybe she particularly
hated slaves for that reason because
they had killed some of her relatives
and things like
but the thing is though after her second
husband died
jean-paul Leblanc he had actually left
in his will like to liberate one of the
slaves for whatever particular reason so
she did actually do that to honor his
wishes and she had also released some of
her own slaves just for good service or
for being particularly faithful or
things like that so it's not like she
had kind of an overarching hatred for
them because some of them it seems like
she treated them okay you know what I
mean there was something going on if
they were doing it the way it was been
described they were doing it for some
kind of a reason yeah I think it or
maybe maybe being nice to black people
in public and being nice to black slaves
in public was it was a cover that's kind
of what I'm thinking something like that
we just had to find out more I don't
know everything about it you know more
about it than I do yeah you did the
research and another thing too was that
a lot of it like I said there were a lot
of like freed black people and you know
yet that the whole culture around New
Orleans were there was a lot of
mixed-race people at the time um so it
wasn't that unusual and actually in
Delphine's family there were a lot of
mixed-race
relatives of hers many of her her dad
had a mixed-race mistress yeah so she
actually had a mixed-race half-sister
who she was by all accounts very nice to
and like you know gave her money and
helped her out and things like that yeah
there's all kind of stuff that was going
on during that time and even after that
time I don't know if you know I don't
know if we mentioned it before in other
shows but I mention it again they had
these things called octoroon
yeah balls and a whole octoroon culture
and octoroon z-- and quadroons were kind
of like the geisha of the south if you
want to say the South was kind of like
feudal Japan which in many ways it was
the octoroon 's and the quadrants would
have Quadron women would have been would
have been geisha yeah and you win it you
couldn't marry them because they had all
the kind of laws usually rich white guys
were into forced marriages with other
rich white women a lot of times they
didn't like
girl it was just something that their
dad yeah it was just like a financial
arrangement it was to merge two empires
together financial empires so you didn't
choose your wife but you could choose
your mistress and you'd enter into a
contract or you had to give her a
certain apartment you had a that if you
had children with an octoroon female
they were considered legally to be white
so you had to raise your children with
him that she had to be kept in a certain
amount of finery and they were educated
they knew that you can you can research
all this they were educated they looked
white when you looked at him they a lot
of them have a red heads and stuff their
mothers were quadroons or and they were
your real wife really more so than your
wife wife that was something that was
arranged for you but they actually
seemed to according to history in all
the writing they actually loved the
mistress it was usually like I said
that's you know that's not a surprising
like you said when marriages were
undertaken for financial reasons and you
might not even know that person
particularly well or like that person
all that money here's weird about now
here's some about octoroon culture our
wounds were so high highly sought after
and they their standard of living was so
high compared to other women at the time
that you had fake operands yeah you had
fully white women straight from Ireland
adopting an American accent and trying
to fake credentials and hire a quadroon
woman to act like her mother at this
damn octoroon ball to [ __ ] cut this
deal that's how that's how pampered they
were there's paintings of them yeah
still exist well I'm like I said even
several of Delphine's male relatives had
mixed-race mistresses that were
acknowledged and the children that they
had from them were also acknowledged and
were left in the will of us so it's not
like it was some dirty secret no
everybody knew they didn't keep it no
you're not around here
[ __ ] especially coming out of the out of
the north with mod in modern times
whether they take the worst situations
that ever happened in the south and they
kind of hold that up as being the norm
when that wasn't really the norm south
even in olden times was a lot more
diverse than people with neck and it was
a lot more freewheeling you know I mean
you had a lot of intermarriage that's
going on yeah
there wasn't any well it in certain
places there weren't laws against it as
long as it was between free people yeah
it was just you know I mean it dependent
county by county well like I said it's
just like and we say this a lot on this
show but it's like everything
particularly history you know obviously
they can only get into so much like in a
history book and stuff like that never
maybe it's just like kind of a general
outline of it but everything is a lot
more complex yeah then you know because
I mean there's just everyone's different
it's like every place was different and
it's like there was just so much
different [ __ ] going on you had free
black men that were plantation owners
and owned slaves and where they were
players real players
you had Indians that owned slaves that's
a weird [ __ ] you had Indians who were
mostly Irish yea the Indians that were
black you know they were part of a tribe
yeah it's just difficult it was
difficult to pigeon-holed anything from
the 17 in the eighteen hundred's here in
America you could run into anything
pretty wasn't this cut and dried
Hollywood wants to paint it to be a
certain way that really like I said it's
easier I mean particularly in like I
said in a history broker and like a you
know fictionalized movie or something
like that I mean you can't have just
like [ __ ] all over the place like in
real life because like people don't
follow narratives like that very well I
don't I mean but I had a whole series of
time-life books that talked about the
Old West and one of them was called the
gun fighters and they showed him hanging
this gang of thieves that were running
around robbing banks and they said that
they went on like a 12 month rape and
robbery and murder spree across all of
California and if you looked at him it
was white guys black guys and Mexicans
all dressed like Cowboys in the same
damn gang
mmm-hmm that's not what you saw out of
Hollywood yeah but that's what it really
was yeah yeah well yeah like I said
everything's a lot more calm life in
general is a lot more complicated than
they could like share in a movie or
whatever yes so all right so pretty much
as soon as you know she had married her
third husband and like I said some
sources say that the how she met him was
that one of her daughters I believe the
daughter's name was Pauline had like
some kind of spinal deformity or
something like that and he was like some
sources said today he'd be like a
chiropractor you know I mean because
he's a doctor but you know he I guess
that was what his specialty was or
whatever so I think that's how they met
and that kind of ties in to some of the
rumors that swirled around him later on
about like medical experimentation [ __ ]
like that but we'll get into that a
little bit so even as early as 1828
shortly after Delphine had married her
third husband Lou Lauri there had been
rumors circulating like I said that she
was mistreating her slaves that people
in the neighborhood whatever would see
her slaves and they looked really bad or
they you know they looked like they had
been beaten or they looked sick or
something or malnourished or what have
what have you so apparently there a
letter survives from 1812 from as early
as 1828 that said that he had gone into
the lalaurie's house and that there was
more than one slave in there who had
clearly been beaten until they were
bleeding he said they were still bloody
quote unquote he also pointed out that
Delphine and her husband did not get
along that they were constantly to each
other's throats they were always
fighting they would often separate and
then get back together like later on so
it was like a real you know tumultuous
relationship let's call it that so as I
said there had been all these rumors
kind of circulating now some of the most
famous accounts of her Delphine's
mistreatment came from a an English
journalist named Harriet Martineau now
she came to New Orleans in 1836 and
started hearing the rumors
and started kind of looking into them so
a lot of the people in the neighborhood
like I said was said her slaves look
really bad another thing that came about
was that apparently Madame milori
when her daughter's like if her
daughter's tried to help the slaves like
tried to feed them or like tried to you
know let them loose or you know help
them with their injuries or whatever
then the mom would beat them to like her
own daughters like she didn't want them
helping the slaves out so there are
records that a young law student was
sent to the house to investigate these
rumors because like I said if she was
doing what the rumor said then that was
in contravention of the law you could
yes you could whip your slaves yes you
could keep your slaves and irons but the
[ __ ] that she was doing was beyond the
pale so she actually did get
investigated for that however when the
guy turned up at the house apparently he
found her so charming and I guess none
of the slaves would say anything against
her that he kind of concluded oh well
maybe there was nothing going on or
maybe there was a lot of stuff
exaggerated and everything like that but
as I said there had they're the rumors
were bad enough that they actually did
send people to investigate now one of
the most famous stories whether this is
true or not I'm not entirely sure but
one of the most famous stories that
circulated about Delphine LaLaurie was
the tale of the slave girl Lea now this
apparently this little girl was
apparently about twelve years old and
was a slave in the household and
apparently neighbors allegedly said that
they saw this little girl running across
the roof of the house on Royal Street
with Madame LaLaurie chasing after her
with a whip and that this little girl
either fell or jumped off of the third
floor or jumped off of the roof of the
mansion and died in the courtyard right
now you know later story said like I
said the the girl is usually given the
name Lea either L EAH or Li a the story
goes that she was kind of like one of
she was one of the slaves that would
like you know take care of her hair and
you know her bath time shed and
everything so apparently the story goes
that this little girl was brushing madam
Liew Lori's hair and like caught a knot
and like pulled it too hard and then it
made Delphine really mad so she started
chasing this little girl through the
house and onto the roof of the whip and
the little girl either fell accidentally
or jumped off because she was like
wasn't having it this story sounds awful
familiar does it doesn't it remind you
of something with that same story that
they told about Countess báthory hmm
yeah but how countess Bathory became a
vampire that's right I forgot all about
that
so I'm suspicious already that's
probably why this was reminding me of
countess Beth like I said and I'm not
saying that Delphine LaLaurie wasn't a
terrible person she was yeah but she did
mistreat people they know that but did
that story actually have this story I'm
not sure that sound we had sounds like
something out of a damn vampire story
yeah I bet you that's not true that's a
legend yeah you know man I think that
was added it may have been like I said
because a lot of things about her were
exaggerated later on particularly after
world war ii countess Bathory story the
countess is getting her she's aging and
she's looking in the mirror and she's
not as pretty as she used to be it's
like something Motta out of a damn
Disney story was Snow White you know to
me and she's like you know looking at
herself in the mirror I'm not was pretty
like I used to be and the peasant girl
who's brushing her hair pulls her hair
this was all you [ __ ] that hurt she
slapped a girl and some blood dripped
out of her mouth right yeah I had
forgotten about how to suck on the grab
the thing and tasted the blood or she
rubbed the blob on herself and that part
of their skin looked newer yeah so she's
excited to use blood it's like oil of
olay
yeah yeah so that's a blood of visitin
that's that's a similar story yeah I
doubt that half
yeah this might have been one of the
things that was exaggerated the thing is
like I said so yes so this little girl
supposedly like either Fowler was or
jumped off the roof and she was
supposedly buried on the grounds of the
l'amore mansion a little girl that each
might have died there um I think that
she did because I do believe that they
did find at least one child skeleton
sickness but it could have been anyone
because they died they died her because
the thing is that they actually did have
records of the names of most of her
slaves and there was not one named Leah
although she did have some slaves that
were that age so it could be that
something similar did happen but that
that wasn't the kids name you know what
I mean
you know so there's also the story to
that either right around the time of
this incident that there was another
investigation into Delphine and her
husband about their particular cruelty
and that at this point I believe it was
nine slaves were actually confiscated
that's a horrible word to use like when
you talk about human beings but we're
confiscated yeah we're confiscated away
from them because of their cruelty
however the story goes what ended up
happening was that they actually ended
up getting those slaves back because
some of their relatives went to the
auction and bought them back and then
gave them back to the Lory bottom on a
discount game back yeah so it was a like
there are some like spotty records of
these types of transactions going on
like I said that the records are you
know patchy so some of this stuff did
happen some of it may have happened but
the records were lost or the you know
the records are contradictory or
something like that so like I said
that's why you know and this wasn't even
as long ago as Countess báthory so you
can see why that kind of thing happens
where you know yeah there was some bad
[ __ ] going on
but you know how much of it was like
added later on to how much of it was
like legend how much of it was like
rumors going around the community like
who [ __ ] knows so yes so very
famously
in April of 1834 a fire broke out at
Lauri mansion and it started in the
kitchen now again story goes when the
police and Fire Marshal's broke into the
house to try to like save people
allegedly they found a 70 year old woman
who was the cook chained to the stove
and she said that she had started the
fire because she wanted to get the [ __ ]
out of there and wanted to get everyone
else out of there she was trying to kill
herself so like I said that's how the
story goes it was it was a suicide
attempt so let me see was that verified
it was in some papers at the time the
the thing about it is that okay so when
the fire happened like people did
actually go in there like delphine and
all them got out but then apparently a
crowd gathered and this is from
newspapers at the time which didn't seem
terribly exaggerated so people started
gathering around and somebody said hey
aren't the slaves still in there are you
guys gonna like go in there and help
them get out or what and apparently the
lalaurie's were like essentially said
why don't you mind your own [ __ ]
business so some of the townspeople as
well as some of the police like busted
in there to try and get the slaves out
because they knew that they were in
there and this is when they found
several slaves I believe it was seven in
the attic who were basically chained to
the wall and had various terrible
injuries you know what I mean they were
very malnourished one of the women and
this might have been the same woman that
they later said was chained to a stove
because I'm not real sure if that was
true or if that was a detail that was
added later they did find an older woman
like chained to a bed in the Attic and
she had like a big knot like a hole in
her head but like a huge big head wound
like she had been like like hit with a
hammer or something like that curious I
would be I'd be curious to know what the
slave
market was like during the time of all
this were these slaves worth money
because there was times in which kind of
like the value of slaves had fallen
through the [ __ ] floor in other words
she couldn't sell them yeah and what I'm
thinking is what had happened did the
new husbands start squandering her
family fortune that she had inherited
directs maybe they were getting too poor
to afford slaves afford this keeping
them in terms of feeding them they
started beating him up and resented them
and then they they couldn't sell him and
then they didn't want to admit that they
were going broke they didn't want a
white people making fun of him that they
were losing their money yeah so they
tried to kill him it could be like
here's the thing I do feel like no way
they can walk away from it yeah
victim and it wouldn't look like that
they were losers going broke right
trying to keep some kind of family honor
it's possible because like I said it had
to have something to do now even though
there is evidence like from her the
letters of her kit like grown children
and stuff like that that Delphine Delory
had some mental issues like for most of
her life probably something like bipolar
disorder because they said sometimes she
seemed super nice and sweet and
everything and then sometimes she was
like very formidable and terrifying you
know what I mean so she kind of had that
type of thing going on however there
were no rumors about her being
particularly cruel or murderous or
anything like that prior to her marrying
her third husband so I feel like there
definitely had to be some kind of
synergy going on or something going on
with her that was triggered by him I
think he was spinning all her money it
could have been or the thing is - yeah
because I don't think he had as much
money as money is there also he was much
younger than her and it might have been
a case where maybe he was [ __ ] around
with one of the slaves or maybe he was
fun and maybe it made her mad um you
know I mean cuz she was getting older
and maybe she thought and that wasn't
something that she was used to because
she had always been like very sought
after because she was very
that's a possibility but I think this I
think would be more likely at this point
is that he was taking her money from her
yeah I'm going town going downtown into
the French Quarter gambling and boozing
and picking up hookers ladies of the
evening all right and he was squandering
her money and she couldn't run the house
after she couldn't run the house with
what she was left with so she couldn't
feed these slaves yeah and then for some
reason she couldn't sell him because you
would think that if you didn't have
enough money to feed slaves then you
could just stay you would you would sell
them yeah because as I said I mean most
horses I said said they had a lot more
slaves than would be it would have been
normal at that time for a household that
size yeah maybe she had some kind of
mental problems and she thought maybe
holding them was in a way saving money
like money in the bank yeah possibly
but I don't know but the way she was she
couldn't feed them like you just have
the same situation going on with crazy
cat ladies sometimes with a whole house
full of starving cats oh I love my cats
I get you know some [ __ ] like that I
can't let these cats go but then they
don't feed the Nelson yeah and then when
they start protesting she start beating
them yeah some with mental problems
maybe that was what happened because
like I said you know so when they broke
in for the fight I mean the house didn't
burn down it was just like you know the
fire started in the kitchen it like
destroyed some of it but they actually
got in and you know and managed to save
the house and it you know got renovated
later on but so they find these seven
slaves I think it was four men two women
and one that they didn't say like what
the gender was but they were basically
chained to the wall by their necks and
had like some kind of mutilations like
they look like their limbs had been
stretched out or that type of thing
like I said the one old woman had like a
really bad head wound they they hadn't
been fed they were very thin and
malnourished and you know various other
things and when they questioned them
they said that they had been up there
for several months hmm know what the
weird thing about this is though it's
like when they actually they
did like rescue all of them and then
they kind of like put them on public
display like not let you know that makes
sense what they wanted people to know
they wanted people to know what she I
guess that was the reason that they gave
they said they wanted to see and they
said like thousands and thousands of
people are on a shaver and they were
trying to shame her and they were trying
to warn other slaveholders yeah that's
probably what it was actually yeah now
because I know a lot some wouldn't
believe it they were really were trying
to control this goes back to [ __ ]
Roman the Roman era yeah they were
constantly trying to put controls on
Roman slaveholders about what you could
do what you couldn't do you know I mean
you couldn't arbitrarily kill slaves
even back in Rome entire day yeah if you
did it you could get it here's the
[ __ ] here's the problem you have
people that don't have access to the
legal system yeah so they can't sue you
they can't file a criminal complaint on
you but then you have a kind of a you
have a civilization that's trying to say
wait a minute
you just can't kill them and torture
them for the fun of it there's got to be
some kind of rules well if you don't
have it access to the damn legal system
how do you do that you can't really
yeah just put up these kind of light
societal ideals and these societal
traditions okay that you're supposed to
follow but there's no punishment for not
following them yeah so it's a huge
problem that was one of the problems
with slavery it's not it's not humane
it's not sustainable you can't do that
fairly there's no way to do that fairly
yeah you can't you can't own another
person and only another person and
expect that but you don't I mean you
can't own another person or you can't
put a person in custody of another
person and then deny that person access
to the legal system so if that person is
abused there could be justice yeah it's
like there's nothing so that's what one
of the things that makes slavery
unsustainable yeah and you know I
understand and you know there's I've met
a lot of people from the north and they
were talking about you know the civil
or they were saying that it was the
civil war that ended slavery that
slavery was expanding and it was getting
richer and was taking over and according
to everything that I've read from that
time and knowing southern culture I'm
gonna tell you
slavery was on the way out anyway it was
not sustainable well Mike she's
technology was making it like I said
there'd been a lot of revolts and [ __ ]
yeah you can't do that yeah for a long
term no especially with the advent of
technology you know as technology got
greater the the the economic need for
slavery it just wasn't there yeah you
didn't need to have a lot of people on a
plantation picking cotton and you know
and woody did
pulling potatoes out of the ground you
could do that with just a two people and
a damn horse with a machine that could
you know the mean sift potatoes from
dirt or a cotton gin so you didn't you
know I mean it was just made it
economically unfeasible yeah and then
like you said the whole thing of
regulating the regulating the behavior
of a slaveholder you have to have a
legal system yeah to do that and and
with if you're going to use the legal
system then that means that the slave
has to have access to the legal system
which means that he's not a slave
anymore yeah so it's just not possible
because it was not a long-term solution
to society's economic problems and you
know just wasn't yeah it was a it's
slavery been going on since the Greek
era between Europeans and then later in
the fifth 1400s it was that the the Pope
okayed the purchase of black slaves on
the market and the European empires
decided to use them and in the new world
you know I mean that's how they got here
the United States didn't invent slavery
we inherited it yeah you know it was
here before the United States had formed
when the United States had formed slaves
were already in it
and it was just kind of a leftover thing
of the European empires and what did it
take about a hundred years for him to
work that out yeah yeah
it was just part of the evolution of
society but you just can't have humane
slavery yeah like I said that's a clean
oxymoron it doesn't work it's a complete
even if you treated them well you still
own that person you don't yeah you know
they don't have any [ __ ] they can't
get away from you they get their legally
bound to like stay there whether they
want to or not
so you it's just not something that's
feasible over centuries and millenniums
you know what I mean civilizations have
gotten away with it for hundreds of
years you know I mean I think black
agricultural slavery went on for about
what 300 years something like that 400
years and that was about you know the
cotton gin had had a lot to do with it
and also population started to expand
yeah got to the point to where the slave
populations you could you could get as
big as you wanted them to well once you
have infinite growth of the slave
population the value of slaves goes down
because there's a lot of them so not
worth as much so any money you invest in
it you'll lose eventually yeah and
that's it kind of what happened with it
and then it just becomes untenable
because how do you manage it without the
legal system it's just there's too many
conundrums it's a [ __ ] it becomes
a cluster thought you're trying to say
best thing you do is to give everybody
rights yeah which that's what eventually
have usually winds up if once everybody
has rights it kind of goat it starts to
work itself out through the natural
means yeah you know we're we arguing
slavery yeah it's like we've sorted that
out buddy it's kind of sorted that out
on us do it yeah along all right I think
we're probably yeah we're right about at
the halfway point so we're gonna take a
break right now for little commercial
little kitty videos and stuff like done
when we come back we will talk even more
about Madame LaLaurie and some of the
more salacious stories that kind of grew
up in the later years about her and
maybe what the truth behind
those myths might be so stay tuned we
will be back in just a few minutes
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
what you doing what you doing
yeah they're at lizard out there
Sarah lizards I bet there is are you
gonna get it are you gonna get it yeah
are you going where are you going oh
don't you do it don't you do it
let me Jason will chase you yes we do
what we do hey when they you gonna play
on that you know you nucleon that you
come here come here what is that
I know yeah are you gonna know what
where'd you go oh I know oh she loves be
just like Quentin Tarantino oh my
goodness get that foot get it get it oh
what love okay bye okay we're back
talking about Delphine LaLaurie
yeah we're I'm here arguing against
slavery I know yeah that's funny pretty
we're arguing against it okay that's
pretty controversial yeah and to take
yeah right I'm being facetious
none of that ship [ __ ] happened out of
the goodness of anyone's heart you know
I mean I mean I think the early
arguments like during the 1400s through
the church just like yeah go ahead and
buy those slaves because we all save
their souls will know how to take care
of it we'll take care of them yeah we
will take good real good care of him
yeah that wasn't out of the goodness of
the heart and and in that [ __ ] wasn't
out of the goodness of their heart
either because they just said yeah you
know what holding these people as slaves
as a [ __ ] yeah you know let's
just make them peasants like everyone
else yeah and we'll toss them a cold
coin and tell them to get the [ __ ] out
of here
yeah cuz you don't take care of them my
lawn
yeah treat him just like a rest of these
[ __ ] white trash [ __ ] oh
yeah pretty much so yeah we're all in
the same boat now seriously yeah yeah
and that you know they're less you have
millions invested millions of dollars
you're hit you're here to be [ __ ]
gonna [ __ ] me at least leave that [ __ ]
alright so as I said so they did
actually rescue seven slaves from the
alluri mansion who had been grievously
mistreated had been chained in the Attic
apparently for several months I don't
know if I mentioned this but they had
also been some of them had been bound
and like really unnatural like
uncomfortable positions and they had
been there for like a really long time
so there you know limbs are all messed
up yeah um you know one of them have
been hit in the head they were all
malnourished and stuff so um so they
take them out of the house they took
them to the local jail as I said and put
them on public display about 4,000
people came out to look at them two of
them subsequently died the other one
survived now shortly after news of this
got out which was pretty much the same
day or the next day a mob of locals
surrounded the lou laurie mansion and
stormed it yeah and pretty much just
went in there in case any more people in
there baby well yeah and they pretty
much like trash the place they looted it
yeah you know all this other stuff they
would they he said like the newspaper
reports at the time said there was
hardly anything left in there like a
buddy just like stripped it bare and
like [ __ ] it up and everything like
that taken they were taking souvenirs
probably and they trashed it also just
because they were [ __ ] mad yeah so
yeah now apparently newspaper reports at
the time said they did actually dig
around the grounds and they did find two
bodies one of which was a kid I don't
know if the other one was an adult but
one of them the first sure was a kid so
whether this was that little girl I
don't know now who did they ask did they
ask the slaves what
happened they just said we've been in
here for several months they didn't
really and they hadn't been eating and
they had just been beaten and whipped
and they were like had you know wit
marks like all over their backs and like
okay so these rumors of these rumors of
torture and [ __ ] no no I'm talking about
the rumors of medical experimentation
that's that's that I think that kind of
came later
okay that was something in exact and I
think that was something that just came
about because because facts of the case
are that one madam will Laurie probably
wasn't up to anything until she married
this doctor and so some have speculated
that maybe it was his thing and he was
like experimenting on them somehow he
was like a chiropractor so maybe he was
like trying to do some spinal [ __ ] but
that to me that seems like a reach yeah
a reaching like I said so the black
people didn't really know why no I did
not that I know of I mean they said
that's evidence right there yeah if you
asking me that's a sign insanity I'm
kind of leaning toward that as well I
mean I think that she that either her or
her and the husband together they
started going nuts started going nuts
and they were just like had some kind of
weirdo Cystic yeah if there was some
kind of a criminal motive to make money
or to do this or that the slaves would
have known what the motive was yeah
because it would have been obvious
there's they saying they don't know what
the motive was or I never read anything
that said that they knew also the only
thing that I've ever read that they said
like when they rescued it was we've been
up here for like several months that was
only new and it's like they're not
feeding us I think that the authorities
would have their chained to the [ __ ]
wall by their necks yeah you addicted
the authorities would have questioning
them they did and like the fact that so
I'm kind of thinking because
particularly after the story came out
like after the fire you know the
newspapers you know were looking for a
reason
they were looking for [ __ ] to like do
you know why this happened why did she
do this and they were trying so the fact
that it doesn't really seem to say any
of that that leads me to believe that I
don't think the victims knew why she was
doing it which means it was something
dumb problem
I'm thinking that what it was is that he
was spending all her money they couldn't
take care of these slaves anymore they
couldn't sell him either
for some reason or another maybe they
weren't worth any money or they were
embarrassed to sell them because that
would prove that they were going that
they were poor yes
so they resented the existent take care
of him they started to starve they
started to starve and then when the
slaves started to look skinny it
reminded them the fact that they were
poor although then there was these weird
mental problems where they're like in
denial the woman and the husband are in
denial so the end up kind of becoming
kind of like these animal hoarders you
know it's not gonna say you know I hate
calling people animals but they're
keeping them like they're animals
yeah and they start acting like an
animal hoarder where the animals are
starving and they won't let the damn
animals go so just stay in these cages
and starve to death I never understand
it well we've seen it on that movie
hoarders on the show you and that show
hoarders that makes me sense it makes no
sense and that's what this sounded like
something out of the hoarders yeah where
they start to suffer these mental
problems and every one of those woman's
that is a hoarder most of them are men
but then mostly it's the women that
admit better on and that are on the show
get on the show they're all mental yeah
okay okay you're [ __ ] crazy if you're
a hoarder if you ask me is just [ __ ]
crazy my grandfather was one yeah
they're crazy all right it's a it's it's
a certain type of craziness though the
rest of them seems to be normal but for
some reason they can't throw the damn
garbage out or they can't [ __ ] the
thing about animal hoarders is you won't
stop [ __ ] buying [ __ ] I almost
understand the animal hoarders more
because here's the thing like if you see
like a poor little wounded kitty like
out
yeah that's orphaned you take it you
want to take it I want to take every
normal person wants to take it and you
want to take it home and take care of an
animal hoarder won't take won't take
care of it but yeah but I so I can
understand that impulse everyone has
that impulse you want to help it you
want to help all these animals and I can
understand being sad that there's so
many animals that are unwanted and that
like you know that get wounded in their
laying and like you want to help them
and rescue them I get that but the
problem
is when you take that empathy which is
good but then you just start collecting
all these animals to a point where you
can't take care of them and their
situation is just as bad as it was
before maybe back in slave days there
was a mental illness that was kind of
like animal hoarding but it only existed
in a society that had slaves to where if
you had slaves okay you get attached to
them and when you couldn't afford them
you couldn't let them go
yeah maybe that's [ __ ] up but I never
thought of that but it might be because
it would be the same as admitting that
you're that you're poor yeah yeah I mean
so maybe it was a situation like that
here's the thing like what you were
saying before about the husband spending
all the money I don't think that was
necessarily the case because um Delphine
LaLaurie neither her nor her husband
Leonard were ever caught for this [ __ ]
because you know what happened after the
mob like stormed the house or like when
it started gathering around the story
goes that Delphine delorean perhaps her
husband as well they're like okay we're
going for our daily you know ride and
the coach like they do every day and he
just never came back I skip town you do
they skip town you could do it back then
now they're not entirely sure so like I
said she never got caught for this [ __ ]
um they're not entirely sure where she
went the most common story is that she
took the coach and then um she went she
got on a boat and went to Mobile Alabama
and then she went back to France now
there are records that she died in
France in 1842
however the weird thing is that there's
also a grave marker in st. Louis
cemetery one in New Orleans that has her
name on it
and it says that she died in Paris but I
think it's like a different year might
have been 1849 so they're not entirely
they're pretty sure that she died in
France and that she was living a pretty
comfortable life with you you know
either one or two of her daughters over
there so I don't think she was broke
dick or anything like that like she just
took off to France and apparently lived
comfortably for the rest of her life
well yeah it's easier to support
yourself and maybe have your daughters
working but how can you support yourself
your daughters and how many
[ __ ] this slaves well like I said I'm
some sources said that was as many as 26
26 slaves
yeah that's a lot of money now they
found seven in the Attic so I'm I don't
know I'm sure an well liked yeah some of
them ran and like I said there are
records to that some of them she had
sold some of them she had emancipated of
various reasons so uh you know it's kind
of like I think she was losing her money
and her mind that's what I think I kind
of feel like she might have been and
like I said it might have been one of
those things because remember we've done
this couple of shows about killer
couples yeah and you know when I say
like sometimes like the woman has some
problems like I said because Madame
LaLaurie like I said from all accounts
and this is from like her children and
stuff like that they loved her but more
than one of them did mention that she
was a little bit well yeah it's like she
could be really sweet and really loving
and something like that and then she
could kind of turn on a dime and like
just be like a hell Beast so I think she
had maybe a little bit of bipolar
disorder going on so she might have had
that already and then maybe she married
this dude and maybe he had some kind of
mental illness too or maybe he
mistreated her or maybe something like
that and the two of them together like
it just kind of evolved in this perfect
storm of [ __ ] because like I said you
know more than one person reported that
their relationship was very contentious
they were always fighting and breaking
up and I think later she alleged that he
had beaten her and things like that so
it wasn't a happy marriage so maybe
there was some kind of trigger between
them or that just when they got together
that kind of happened because it seems
like she didn't do anything bad that
anybody knows of until she married that
dude I'm not saying it was his fault
I don't think he was involved with the
actual torture maybe or he knew about it
but didn't do shame done that on her own
physically or do you think maybe she
could order other slaves to tie up all
this lace well that's possible too maybe
she didn't want to get her hands dirty
maybe she would just like tell them to
do it and she or she would do worse to
them or something like that it's like
might have been a situation like that
yeah yeah and then you got slaves of
damn Stockholm Syndrome slaves okay I'll
do it
well yeah well
when you're seeing this crazy woman like
doing this to other people you're like
well [ __ ] I better do what she says
otherwise she's gonna do that [ __ ] to me
I don't want that done to me yeah like
you can understand how it happens you
know it's like if you're in a situation
where an away with the [ __ ] he gonna go
yeah you know to me there wasn't they
didn't have anyway I have a feeling the
authorities found out they knew but they
just didn't publicize it it could be
because it would have been easy to get
down to the bottom of yeah those slaves
would have told him yeah that I told
exactly what happened yeah who tied him
up what situation was they would have
known they weren't dumb yeah it's just
some reason the authorities didn't want
to talk about what happened maybe and
like I said she was kind of like very
well placed in society she had a lot of
money her family was very prominent yeah
more lines in the cops oh they might
have covered some [ __ ] up and the cops
back in those days were glorified renico
you know like mall cops really yeah most
of them you know I mean the only ones
that would you could really recognize as
a real police force back in those days
have been something like the Pinkertons
yeah which were like a mercenary police
force you know but your average local
cop was just like a rent-a-cop yeah so
well I'm like we said before it's like
they couldn't catch a cold unless they
saw some [ __ ] happening in Ferndale
days because it's not like they had they
didn't even have fingerprinting at this
stage yeah there was no investigation
that soon really happened until the end
of the 19th century all they could do is
cook pasta together and [ __ ] run out
there and look for somebody if they they
already knew who it was or you know if
it was just like well you're the first
person that looks guilty so you did it
crime solved yeah no professional police
forces no not really
like I said this was this is very early
yeah it's early to mid 19th centuries
well we resolved that it didn't have
anything to do with human
experimentation though not like I said
not that I know of that seemed like
something that came about later like as
the legend grew when I first heard it
that was the I that was the theory that
stuck with my mind I first heard about
this probably about 25 years ago
yeah years ago it's a very famous story
it's one of the very famous you know
ghost stories horror stories like
surrounding New Orleans and I was kind
of left the impression
I have something to do with the medical
industry well I'm like I said that way
but here aren't you hearing the stuff
that you just dug up on it that I would
say I'd say no I think that just came
about because her husband happened to be
a doctor
they they come they inflated this story
to make it more and more impressive what
it really was just [ __ ] losses [ __ ]
[ __ ] be crazy that's really what the
story is [ __ ] be crazy
well [ __ ] be crazy cuz that because
their husbands make them crazy well this
was particularly must-have because she
was all right before this yeah that that
this crazy [ __ ] happened yeah so yeah
but what did I think I was just thinking
about this the other day one that I
think George Carlin said that that he
said that was part of one of his acts he
says men are stupid and women are crazy
and women are crazy because men are
stupid always thought that was very
funny so okay so as I said now it's
pretty well documented that Delphine
LaLaurie horribly horribly mistreated at
least seven people maybe killed two
people they found two bodies in the inn
hurt on the grounds of the mansion
whether they died from natural causes or
more murdered
I don't really know know if a slave dies
I don't think just Berryman meant random
places around the house there was good
that's what's yeah there were they were
always like little slave cemetery
cemetery a cemetery like a normal person
yeah they died I'm here right there on
the plantation yeah yeah these were like
on the grounds of the mansion and one of
them was a kid so like I said I don't
know if they died of natural causes I'm
kind of doubting it in light of the [ __ ]
that they found like when they went up
to this attic so in their defense though
it wasn't a plantation so there wouldn't
been room for yeah they were like right
in the middle of the city here in the
middle of the city so but still there
was yeah tears I mean there's summit
there were there were slave cemeteries
outside of the town that's what I mean
and black there are calls that you
follow yeah when someone dies of natural
causes believe
didn't bury little girls on your damn
pond your damn property right that's
what I'm saying so that's why I kind of
think that these situation that these
allegedly the two bodies that they found
were either murdered or they died
because of their treatment because like
I said these slaves they were in bad
shape the ones that they rescued the
seventh of them two of them died late
like after they rescued them because you
didn't bury people in town yeah
you could bury people on around your
house if you lived out in Nebraska or on
your farm or something but that wasn't
in town right yeah this was like the
middle isn't it one of the New Orleans
yeah
Royal Street like I said this is still
there yes there kid you you really
weren't supposed to be doing that yeah
which like I said that's why suspicious
fishy yeah so right so as I said what
she did was bad enough and like I said
in a slave owning place there was enough
rumors swirling about her that she had
detectives going there they had you know
checking on her because of the [ __ ] that
was going on about her so what she did
was bad enough however over the years I
feel like a lot of embellishments have
been added to a point where when you say
Delphine LaLaurie because some of the
documentaries that I saw her better were
pretty like fact-based but a lot of the
ones that I saw like particularly ones
that were more like of a paranormal bent
or their you know trying to say the
mansion's haunted and stuff like that
went with the more fanciful you know
details that kind of didn't really you
know they weren't in the newspapers at
the time but they only kind of came out
later on like in later books about New
Orleans you know history and [ __ ] like
that so I think that some of the details
were added later on one of the probably
one of the books that's most responsible
for a lot of the more you know out there
details about Delphine de Lori was
called ghost stories of New Orleans
which came out in 1946 now in this book
they said that they basically called
Delphine Lori a sadist and they said
that the male slaves that they had found
in the Attic
were naked and chained to the wall which
that's true but then they went on to say
that their eyes were gouged out that
their fingernails were pulled out by the
roots some of them that they quote
unquote had their joints skinned and
festering big slices taken out of their
buttocks this is what I remember yes so
this is like a very common story about
this that their ears had been like kind
of cut off and we're just like kind of
hanging there like in strips that and
I've heard this too that she would cram
[ __ ] in their mouths and then sew their
mouths shut
some of them were said to have had
intestines pulled out and like knotted
around their waist like a belt
one guy was said to have had a hole in
his skull now notably I think one of the
skeletons that they found in the in the
on the grounds did have a hole in his
skull so that might be where this story
comes from but the story goes that when
they found this guy in the Attic that he
had a hole in his skull like he was
still alive but he had a hole in his
skull and then he had like either a
stick or a wooden spoon inserted into
the hole the better to stir his brains
with oh yeah yeah so like I said a lot
of these stories kind of came about
later on like I said no thank you from
the cops or saying no this was not in
any new any contemporary reports of the
fire or the people that they found like
I said that [ __ ] is true it was in the
papers as far as I know the two bodies
that they found and the like I said I
think one of the bodies did actually
have a hole in the skull but all this
stuff about OSA their intestines were
pulled out or their mouths were sewn
shut or things like that I think all of
that was later exaggeration because I
don't think there was anything like that
wasn't mentioned back in the day and
particularly because I mean the [ __ ]
that she did do was bad enough I mean a
[ __ ] mob like took over her house and
just like tore tore it up so everyone
was angry and a lot of the newspapers
were looking for [ __ ] about her like
she's right about it so they would have
written
was what had happened but as far as I
know that wasn't in the newspapers at
the time no according to everything that
you told me the slaves were put were
taken to the jail because that's where
you could hold them yeah all right not
not as criminals but just as victims
yeah they were taken to the jail and
then they were put on display so the
people could see the abuse that they
went under yeah and based on what you're
telling me I think the main abuse was
starvation and a wall and they were
bound in like really uncomfortable
positions like they couldn't move and
stuff yeah and that could cause nerve
damage
yeah it's slightly paralyzed some of it
permanently some of it's only temporary
and they had really like bad like their
backs were flayed like from whips and
suddenly we're so though it you know it
was bad yeah here whipping on him and
stuff it was bad so yeah so they're
gonna be put on display as an example
yeah so obviously their injuries were
bad enough yeah but the other [ __ ] that
sounds a little far-fetched to me yeah
because like I said if this shouldn't
happened then there would have been
stuff in the newspapers about it about
my job and there wasn't all right and
and they would had they would have
burned that house down yeah I mean they
did they did trash it I like everything
but I kind of like what they did to old
[ __ ] what's-his-name's [ __ ]
torture Palace they burned that [ __ ] who
HH Holmes hey Jay Jones yeah this
reminds me a little bit of that too now
and like I said HH Holmes and we've done
a show about him as well and like I said
I don't want anybody to think that I'm
minimizing like the [ __ ] that they did
not was bad enough I'm not minimizing
what countess Bathory did I'm not
minimizing what HH Holmes did I'm not
minimizing what Delphine LaLaurie did
what they did was bad enough yeah we
should get into the truth you don't have
to nod [ __ ] on to it and it's like it in
a way it makes me sad that you have to
add [ __ ] on tilt like to make people
care it's almost kind of like that which
is kind of upsetting well it's kind of
goes to show that even though even back
in the slave days they had compassion
and common sense for people and there
was outrage that they did that to those
people even though those people were
slaves yeah and I mean Eretz person
didn't like newspaper accounts at the
time and so I'm imagining this is
probably true or is only just
slight exaggeration apparently some
people that had gathered around the
house and the mob like it you know
during the fire we're like hey your
slaves are still in there are you going
to go in there and get them and
apparently the lalaurie's were like meh
yeah and they didn't like that and they
didn't like that so and they wouldn't
give them the keys to the house because
apparently they had locked it up they
were trying to kill those slaves yeah so
the people like busted in there to help
them so not you know what I mean so I do
feel like there was probably the
townspeople were like hey those are
still human beings you can't just leave
them in there like that yeah you know
what I mean so now like I said the woman
that allegedly started the fire I think
one of the slaves might have started the
fire on purpose for that very reason
like trying to kill themselves or they
were trying to because I think that was
in the papers at the time however I'm
not sure if the woman that did it was
actually chained to the stove or if that
was a later exaggeration it's possible
because she did chained up a lot of the
slaves in the Attic so it wouldn't
surprise me if she was chained to the
stove but apparently they did question
this woman and she said I was trying to
kill myself and like just take ever take
them out with me pretty much it is what
she said yeah so one of the slaves did
deliberately start the fire like so
apparently there was some bad [ __ ] going
on to hope for someone to have taken it
to that extreme yeah but like I said you
know all this stuff about like you know
the mouths being shown shot and stuff
like that that I don't think that was
the case like I said they would have
mentioned it I think they would have
mentioned it the time yeah and what she
did was bad enough now so there was all
that and that seems like the most common
[ __ ] then it got kind of even worse like
in the late 1990s there was another book
that came out called journey into
darkness which was kind of about ghosts
and New Orleans and this came from like
more paranormal kind of thing because I
guess the woman that wrote it like owned
a ghost tour business as she was kind of
like trying to drum up business for the
ghosts or I guess so she's trying to
make everything look sound as scary and
creepy as possible and she added even
more details to this to this story like
which was already starting to get like
kind of crazy yeah where are these
details coming from just like where it
you know I mean nothing out of the
original account where are you getting
your details right this is always the
[ __ ] icky
he's healed all these tall tales yeah
with those first original and I'm not
saying that newspapers back then I mean
they exaggerated [ __ ] - it's like that
you know what I mean they want to sell
papers just like they want to do
nowadays it's well it's not papers
anymore but you know they want clicks
now yeah you know now they want clicks
so it's like and the best way to get
that is outrage so you want to piss
people off you want to like horrify
people you want you know they knew that
back then obviously and it's not really
any different so I feel like if this
[ __ ] had really happened then for sure
they would have printed yeah for sure
fish they showed what what they had they
put them on display they were starved
they were whipped some of them died from
the whippings yeah and they were chained
up and they was like you know they even
horribly tortured me they would never do
when they were tied in certain places
who did it probably other slaves under
the command of that woman I don't think
that woman could have done it on her own
but still the way it was she was still
responsible yeah of course
still responsible and they held her
responsible yeah it's just she gave him
the slip and they never did find her
because my friends back in those days
you know I mean you could order a slave
to do something to another slave he had
to do it well yeah like I said what
recourse did they have because they
probably thought you would just do the
same thing to them so that's what
happened she's that [ __ ] was crazy yeah
yeah so this book that came out in 1998
like I said this woman that you know
it's a ghost tour and she added a few
more details - and these are very
creative [ __ ] she said that one of the
victims had her arms amputated
there were also stories - that some of
them had their arms amputated and like
put on different parts of their body no
wonder that medical experiment so one
had like a very crude gender
reassignment surgery like a sex change
that was another one that they said so
this woman supposedly had her arms cut
off and her skin quote peeled off in a
circular pattern making her look like a
human caterpillar Wow
then she said that there was another one
another slave who had had her limbs
broken and reset at odd angles so she
resembled a human crab so like I said I
think I think a lot of this [ __ ]
added later on yes [ __ ] that she did was
bad enough because you know here's the
thing now so let's talk a little bit
about what may be the truth behind some
of this stuff is because like I don't
know where the caterpillar story came
from I don't know where that [ __ ] came
from Ellen booth maybe they well yeah
and maybe they got that from a movie or
something like got that [ __ ] from one of
the tusks
watch that movie you guys but yeah so
let's get back to remember when I was
talking about the story about Lea the
little girl that supposedly jumped or
fell off the roof of the house and like
I said they did find a body of a child
in the on the grounds of the mansion
however the records do not show that she
had a slave named Lea
however she did have child slaves and
there were some child slaves that were
never officially listed as sold or
officially listed as died and then they
seemed to kind of like disappear from
the records later on so it's kind of
possible it's like even though they
doubt that the whole thing with her
chasing the girl with the whip and [ __ ]
like that they do think some child
slaves might have died under her care
between 1831 and 1834 and no one really
did anything about it so she might have
been doing this like chaining them in
the Attic and torturing them for a long
time like a lot of them might have died
prior to that and there was no record of
it because the parent I mean they did
keep records of people like they had you
know because it was properly like you
said said they did have a record of like
who bought it and when it was and when
they died and all this other kind of
stuff and they there were some kids that
she had in her possession that later on
they weren't in her possession anymore
and there was no record of them being
sold and there was no record of them
dying so it's possible that they that
she had killed them or kept him chained
in the attic and then buried him
somewhere else yeah
and but then you got to start making a
keys you know I mean you got to make
accusations without proof when you do
that you also have to consider that
maybe she just gave him away that
happened a lot too true
but you know like I said she did some
bad [ __ ] to people they you know it was
only seven that they found there were a
lot in her in the records of her
purchasing them and then they don't know
what happened to him afterward um I'm
thinking based upon the totality of my
experience with these cases that you
read to me
chances are chances are this [ __ ] kind
of had a psychotic break and that most
of the bad [ __ ] that she did she did in
those final years it does seem to be
like a very I'm thinking window that
this was the end her slave holding
period she's doing this [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] well like I said it was about a
three or four year period yeah and I'm
thinking that it was a period of
financial collapse and emotional
collapse yeah could be that she'd come
across some children you know through
inheritance or whatever how did she get
him purchase Aaron Aaron yeah purchase
purchase I don't think she inherited any
of them okay she let a few of them go
they do have record of that I think
three she may have given him to other
family members although the thing is
okay now and remember to like what I
said about the whole thing about nine
slaves being taken from her house and
then um you know for maltreatment
supposedly and then them like her a
relative like buying the back and giving
them back to her
one thing that really did happen that
was documented in 1828 and this was kind
of like right when the rumors were first
starting you know about her mistreatment
of them you know what I mean this was
right after she had married the third
husband um she apparently for no reason
just very suddenly she sold six of her
slaves to a friend of the family whose
name is Louie Bruni air and then she
sold and that he sold four of those to
another person and then this other
person sold the four of them back to
Delphine LaLaurie so some people so
there
our records of all those transactions so
that seemed a little weird now three of
those slaves they have records of them
dying the other one they don't so I'm
not sure if that's where the whole nine
slaves taken from the house and then
sold back because this did happen but
they're wondering like why she suddenly
decided hey I got to sell these six
slaves to this person and then later on
through you know through an intermediary
she got them back well from her point of
view she maybe she didn't want to sell
them but she had to sell them because
she didn't have the money so she needed
the money so she sold him as a group
yeah got the money that she needed it
but then later when the financial system
was a little bit better she saw those
same slaves being sold at a discount for
maybe pennies on the dollar or something
says all I can get him back yeah you
know I mean maybe but you know like it's
not like that so here's the thing - and
I was reading this kind of like really
long like historical account of what
maybe had there were some things that
I've read about over the years about
this whole [ __ ] slave business a lot
of times they lost a lot of money on it
yeah because because the value of slaves
fluctuated with the market and the age
of the slaves sounds ridiculous talking
about human beings like this yeah but
that but that was the truth of the
matter and sometimes they would these
guys would be holding slaves and they
really couldn't feed them so they had to
get rid of him yeah because a lot of
times just because you had a slave he
was worth money didn't mean necessarily
that he was making money for you yeah so
you had to get him in the hands of a
holder that could work him to make
profit it was it was a lot more
complicated than you than you would
think
yeah but then holding slaves somehow
gave you a high status it was like
owning a bunch of cars or a bunch of
thoroughbred horses you know and I mean
yeah in the eyes of a bank they might
give you a big loan because you have
these slaves yeah
even though you're losing your ass on it
so it's not it's not a legitimate
business think about it yeah game that
[ __ ] system like crazy
ya know yeah you could lose your ass you
could hook you could you could take out
loans with
that could never really be repaid there
was a lot of element of scam yeah yeah
no so that's probably a lot of what's
going on it'd be hard for a modern
person to understand why they did the
things that they did it was because they
were trying to game systems that don't
exist anymore today that we're not real
familiar with yeah you know what I mean
mm-hmm like you know go out and try to
take out a loan in the bank based on the
[ __ ] collateral of some slaves of
your holding you can't do it yeah they
would go what yeah but they were doing
that kind of stuff so for us as modern
people to try to make sense out of what
they were doing and be it's kind of
harder I think
yeah people in the past are just image
people in the past or more of a mystery
because they were dealing with a
different legal system and different
banking system yeah there's a different
culture for it yeah it was a whole
different deal yeah so I think a lot of
the stuff that they were doing must have
been just temporary situations trying to
get a temporary advantage over a system
yeah you know I mean like oh well I'll
buy them I'll buy those things back for
pennies on the dollar and that'll help
out the situation with the bank I'll
tell them that they're [ __ ] 10 years
younger than they really are yeah that
kind of stuff yeah you know I mean the
thing is like I said there's probably no
way of knowing now but some people have
pointed out that that transaction just
seemed a little suspicious you know what
I mean in light of because this was
right around the time when rumors about
her first started and like you know the
law clerk went to her house to
investigate and all this other stuff so
some people are saying that maybe she
sold these particular slaves offs like
just until the investigation was over
like just kind of get them out of her
hair and then she like bought them back
later on um well look we know this for
sure we know this slaves were worth
money Irish were not worth money was
slaves were worth money every time
they're buying and selling slaves banks
are involved and has something to do
with the can money and money you know I
mean in your credit system we know that
if you buy slaves and then kill slaves
you lose money that if you abuse slaves
that's the same as burning up money so
the
you take slaves and you lock them up in
a damn attic and beat him and starve
them and torturing them you're really
losing money doing that yeah you know I
mean that's not in your advantage so
that'd be like buying [ __ ] awesome
property and then burning the houses on
the property you dealing with insanity
that's what you're dealing well and the
thing - he's doing this well and
something [ __ ] crazy and some people
have pointed out - that it's like you
know yes what they caught her doing was
bad enough but it could be that her
wealth and her political connections
because like I said you know she had a
cousin that was you know the mayor for a
time and you know there were very
prominent family that maybe she was
actually kind of doing worse and they
covered it up a little bit and as
evidence of this they point to another
member of her family who was a cousin of
hers named Madame Lula noose and a year
you know prior to Delphine LaLaurie 's
you know that whole investigation into
her cruelty to her slaves Madame la News
had pretty much the same thing going on
at her house and actually she was
brought she was kind of like brought in
about it because she had actually
whipped one of her slaves to death and
also you know brutalized one so badly
that she died later on now there are
records of that but then it kind of
disappears from the record so it's
almost kind of like she knows she was
wealthy so it was kind of like swept
under the carpet a little bit yeah so
and this happened like a before like
Delphine little race thing yeah so I I
feel like it might have been you know
her [ __ ] might have been hushed up too
but maybe it was harder to hush up
Delphine LaLaurie stuff because it was
right there in the little of New Orleans
and like everybody saw it
so it was a lot more public maybe than
what happened with her cousin you know
what I'm saying well it's common
knowledge that that slaves were punished
if they got out of line yeah
if they committed a crime they were
killed yeah or punished depending on
what were the severity of the crime
slaves are worth money okay you didn't
want to kill or punish one too much
because you'd end up losing your
investment so in fact their innate value
protected them to a certain extent the
only time a slave would be killed would
be in extreme circumstances like to stop
some kind of slave revolt or the slaves
too dangerous to have around now he
didn't mean there something like that it
would happen accidentally probably
during punishment you could say that
would probably that probably happens
certain times but I don't think this
ever happened because of any kind of
pleasure no no you know what I mean it'd
be very rare if you had some kind of
sexual sadist doing this just for fun
because that would be like that would be
rare that'd be like buying thoroughbred
horses and then just whipping the horses
to death yeah although like I said I'm
sure it happened that it happened
because there's raisi people there are
always crazy people but that wouldn't be
the norm and I do think that Delphine
LaLaurie was crazy for sure and maybe
her husband was pretty out there crazy
this isn't normal this is crazy [ __ ]
it'd be like why would you buy a Ferrari
you know what I mean and then run it
into a wall yeah yeah no slaves had
value inhumane if slavery was an
inhumane system but you did but slaves
had value that was a power in itself you
know I mean they had a certain amount of
protection theoretically you know the
kind of usually that's the way it went
yeah you know as long as they were
working they were protected yeah you
know uh this whole idea of somebody just
buying slaves to torture and kill him
that's [ __ ] insane yeah well like I
said she I don't know how long she had
had the particular slaves that they
found later on um but I think this is
something that evolved over time this
the only only sense I can make out of
this is that she had some kind of
financial and psychological emotional
collapse [ __ ] went crazy maybe
[ __ ] went crazy well like I said why
don't you went crazy [ __ ] is losing her
money I guarantee you well when she was
when I was just talking about her cousin
and how she was kind of brought in on
similar charges of like you know
egregiously like torturing her slaves
one of whom actually both of whom died
but
one of them died at the time and one of
them died a little bit later so there
are records of that and then it was kind
of hushed up and interestingly the same
thing kind of happened with Delphine
LaLaurie it's like it seems like you
know there are records that somebody
went to her house to investigate there
are records that she was brought up on
cruelty charges but then nothing came of
it however there does survive a record
of her hiring an attorney for what was
then $300 which is over $7,000 now and
then like no more records exist so some
of speculate matters that she yet that
she either had expunged her that was
used to just like pay off the court
because a lot of wealthy people did that
back then so like I said it's it's not
so much that she didn't do the [ __ ] it
was just she got away with it because
she had money you know what I mean like
just like nowadays she'd get away she
saying she had a prior offense yeah well
no this was when she was brought up on
the cruelty charges like I said there is
a record of like some money exchanging
hands of her hiring a defense attorney
and then after that the problems seemed
to go away so some have speculated that
that was like a payoff you know that
they were paying off witnesses paying
off the judge whatever you know I mean
so so there's some [ __ ] about that too
that maybe you know she had done some
[ __ ] before but because she was money
she had money because it happened before
like with other members of a family that
had done the same kind of [ __ ] so you
know even though like I want to say that
like I said what she did was bad enough
it just seems like it's it makes me a
little bit upset that all of this [ __ ]
had it like it makes a good story
obviously like I just want to show just
like the HH Holmes like murder castle
and crap like that but you know so I
don't know it's kind of an interesting
case though and it's like I kind of want
to get a little bit into this one thing
that I was reading about similar cases
like what ended up happening like what
she did and like some other [ __ ] that
was going on that was weird um her that
we'll never know because I'm I'm just
I'm just going off on a little bit of a
because I was knew I was gonna give my
verdict well I give it a deal well you
can say it now if you want to I think
she was just an unstable woman who had a
history of cruelty she at least had a
prior offense she said yeah they got
expunged mean [ __ ] [ __ ] man
yeah yeah well she definitely was
definitely yeah I don't think she was as
bad as Countess báthory though I don't
think there was a sexual motive yeah
countess Bathory seems unusual in the
sense that she's a very rare like female
sexual sadist you don't really see I
think we would not you I think this
chick was [ __ ] going broke and kind
of losing her mind and taking it out on
[ __ ] people that she could they're
the people that underneath her who were
her slaves
yeah yeah I mean yeah and the thing too
is that you know like I said the way she
treated slaves that was bad it wasn't it
was unusual but it wasn't unheard of and
I mean particularly because I mean a lot
of slave owners were you know aware of
the slave revolts that happened in Haiti
and so I think they were kind of
paranoid about their slaves doing the
same kind of [ __ ] so it's almost kind of
like they went in either one of two
directions there was like oh well we
have to be super nice to them or we have
to like crack down on them yeah to you
know to like kind of intimidate them
into not doing that
yeah um because there were some cases
there was like one account from the very
early 1800s where a lot of plantation
slaves and this is like out of the
plantation like not in the middle of New
Orleans or anything like that but where
they would take those slaves and they
would like stretch them out like they
would tie all their limbs to like steaks
like they would strip all their clothes
off and like lay them out and [ __ ] like
that and they would then they would whip
them like that you know and and even
like they would abuse like pregnant
women and [ __ ] like that
there was one anybody got out of line
you were [ __ ] punished yeah and like
I said some of the punishments were way
worse true and they probably needed to
be although you know they were [ __ ]
even worse in Africa when the
and like the Belgians because because
there were European colonies inside of
inside of Africa and I was reading about
one there's a Belgian colony that had
[ __ ] disagreement with the Africans
that were there they were working too
slow they'd cut their hands off I'd
never heard anything like that in the
South yeah like I said I'm sure it
happened but I mean there was one I was
gonna say there was one there was one
account from 1863 I believe where there
was one woman she had just had a baby
and she was still like but she was still
breastfeeding the baby and apparently
this woman was whipped a hundred times
when she did something that the mistress
didn't like and then the woman tried to
han dirty lashes yeah and then tried to
seal her nipples shut with hot tongs
because she thought she was spending too
much time feeding the baby and not
attending to her work damn is that true
that's what there was an account of it
from 1863 that somebody heard about and
that's what I mean that's [ __ ] up so
[ __ ] up [ __ ] didn't happen you know
I'm not saying that that couldn't have
been approved of my whites even back in
those days though there just couldn't
have been that's what I mean well and
the fact that the fact that that was
written about yeah like in a magazine at
the time like an account of it that's
what I'm gonna say was because like I
said none of it's good yeah I'm just
saying that you know it was a [ __ ]
what what Delphine de Laurie Laurie did
it was like it was bad but there was
other people doing it too but it wasn't
thankfully it wasn't quite as calm yes
that's [ __ ] totally inhumane as if
slavery could ever be humane we get back
into that argument again yeah yeah
slavery can never be humane and it's
it's kind of funny that they tried to
put regulation regulating forces on it
to try to make it more humane it's just
it's just never gonna be humane yeah
this isn't it you just gotta give
everybody their human rights yeah you
know yeah and you just just pay it you
solve so many problems when you just pay
people for their work yeah it's like
it's so easy so simple see so [ __ ]
simple I mean even if you don't give a
[ __ ] about people yeah
you're really lazy pea but there are
gonna be problems way down the line and
you just want to make people work if you
just pay [ __ ] it solves and many
problems well if you just pay them
enough to [ __ ] live on yeah you know
that would be nice but yeah so um so
like a like I said in later years like
even though I'm not trying to exonerate
her she was a very terrible person now
some people just like in the case of
Countess báthory some people have tried
to completely exonerate Madame LaLaurie
by saying that she was essentially set
up um I feel like there's not really a
lot of evidence for this there's only
like a few writers that have kind of
gone to bat for her instead they sound
like bath read now yes well that's what
I say that's why this case were very
very strongly reminds me of that yeah um
so it seems like so there's this guy
named Stanley Arthur who was the
president of the board of curators at
Louisiana State Museum and he thinks
that she didn't do anything and he
different than any other slave owners at
the time and that she was basically
railroaded in the media but because you
know he's saying stuff like oh well she
seemed like such a nice lady in town and
stuff and maybe people were just haters
or were jealous of her of her position
and her wealth and all this other kind
of stuff so they just made this stuff up
about her but I was kind of like well
that's kind of hard to square with the
fact that all of these people who went
into the house after the fire found
these seven people in the attic it's
like that seems that would seem hard to
explain away as just like oh the media
made it all up because if it's like
there was a lot of townspeople that were
there and saw it happened they saw all
those people come out and you know they
could see and like 4,000 people came to
the jail and saw the people that they
were all tortured and [ __ ] yeah they saw
it yeah so it's just crazy so but I've
seen some people that were kind of
trying to make it seem like oh she was
completely innocent of all wrongdoing
say that either oh it was because you
know the you know Louisiana had been
sold to the United States and then like
these people were coming in they didn't
like the Creoles and there was all this
other kind of stuff and they all
their own newspapers and they were
trying to like you know tarnish her name
or whatever but the ones that we're
talking about her crimes were Creole
owned newspapers she like she was a
Creole as well so it's kind of like it
wasn't like oh it was an English
newspaper oh it was like some other you
know this thing that was like out to get
her or anything like that they were the
same as she was you know and they were
just reporting like what they found I've
also heard that that there was like a
neighbor or somebody that lived around
there that had like was like unrequited
love for her and after she married
someone else like he decided he was
going to destroy her reputation so he
made up all this stuff about her so I've
kind of heard that as well but like I
said it seems a little that seems a
little far-fetched I mean considering
how much how many witnesses there were
to like it was in what she did yeah the
work the the the starving slaves were
shown to the public this is all evidence
that they considered all this to be bad
yeah and that this wasn't normal yeah I
mean obviously like I said someone did
happen like she was something had she
had to be doing something bad because
here's the thing pretty much all wealthy
families owned slaves okay all wealthy
families had owned slaves most of them
would probably punish their slaves if
they did something they didn't like it
was just a thing that people did it was
legal they did to their children - but
yes everything so it's like you know
beating them [ __ ] like that like that
would have been like the norm sadly yeah
so the fact that rumors were circulating
about her years beforehand and that
people were outraged enough by what they
saw that they just [ __ ] mobbed her
house yeah you know like looking for her
handbag did so it must have been really
bad even by the standards of the time
because otherwise everyone would have
been like oh yeah well and the standards
of that day was punishment was normal it
was yeah and like I said it was
perfectly legal it was perfectly legal
to whip them with your rod like them
with a rod you could chain them up even
you joined the Navy
you could be whipped for for failing to
do your duty you could be keelhauled
would you look up all that [ __ ] there's
a say
thing with the army you could be whipped
you could put the stockade
you know they so it wasn't just slaves
that were whipped everyone was everyone
yeah you know that's what I mean it
wouldn't have been seen as unusual yet
whatnot because like I said happen in
the military it was like it was just
nothing that he's not trying to
normalize slavery no I'm just that
slavery was a normal normal thing of
those days yeah and it and the things
that they did to slaves were pretty
normal a aside from buying and selling
people that wasn't [ __ ] normal to you
know yeah that's not imagination but
punishing people was normal everybody
got punished yeah I mean you know you
could commit a crime and you and your
punishment could be ten lashes and
they're in the square
yeah you know that happened it depend on
the county yeah but I think they even
did that in the Old West I think I think
washing sometimes was in certain
counties so you'd have some dude out
there getting 20 lashes yeah it's not
good it's just it was gone it wasn't
just something you did to your slaves
that was something that they did
everybody in westerns in general like as
a punishment really I'd rather get 20
lashes then do a year or six months in
prison just get it over with
just get it off it's like it hurts and
[ __ ] like that but it's like a lot yeah
it's it's short-lived I mean a year
that's a whole year your life you'll
never get back right but yeah so as I
said um you know a lot of Legends have
grown up about her over the years just
because you know she was super bad but
apparently not bad enough for people's
like salacious appetites and they have
to add all this stuff about skinning
people and making them look like human
caterpillars and whatnot to like I said
to make anybody care about the victims
which really kind of I don't think I
don't think there was that much effort
in it she just would get pissed off and
she would tell one slave to give that
other slave 20 lashes unlock yeah some
have said that her accomplice um cuz I
don't know if anyone really thinks I
mean some people said oh maybe her
husband was involved in it too
but a lot of accounts I read said that
her accomplice actually might have been
her coach driver it was it he was a
slave to but he was like real well fed
yeah and everything and he was kind of
like the foreman he was like her partner
in crime kind of like he and apparently
he would like go around and like
gnarrk on the other ones yeah like some
accounts have said that so well here's
we had that system set up right so
they're thinking that maybe she used
that guy to like help because you like
you said I think most people know that
you know she was just you know a slight
little woman it's like she's not gonna
be able to wrangle like a full grown man
and [ __ ] like that like all by herself
so they think that she probably had help
and they said if it wasn't her husband
then it was probably her driver because
that was like her that was Kanna you
know there's the stereotypical kind of
thing where you've got kind of like a
German slave driver you know a lot of
times it was just another black dude
he's just a high he had higher rank yeah
and like I said it's not like you know
he probably didn't want to do it but I
you know it's like you get to a point -
I'm the foreman he had seniority and he
became trusted and you didn't wanna you
don't want to lose that you know ya
edition just take off cuz on the
plantation he would have his own little
house right and you know he'd have a
live-in woman and would get out of me
and get rewarded more so he had a higher
position that he needed to protect ya
you know and they're selected they're
selected for the personality you know
their qualities you know the means of
course they're gonna be hard driving
[ __ ] that make of the [ __ ] yeah
you know well of course like I said boss
tiny mentality yeah but yeah so like I
said um the mansion still stands in New
Orleans today and is a very popular stop
on many ghost tours however it is a
private residence
you cannot go inside but you can go
around the outside fun fact it was
actually owned by Nicholas Cage for two
years he bought it I don't think he ever
lived in it but he bought it presumably
because of the you know reputation that
it had because that seems like something
he would do I don't think he ever lived
in it but then like two years later when
he was going through all that tax
evasion problem he got it taken away but
yeah so he did own it for a little while
oh speaking of Nicolas Cage he is going
to be in there doing an adaptation of
the HP Lovecraft story color out of
space finally I don't think they've ever
done that before have they
he's gonna [ __ ] cage the [ __ ] out of
them I say I watch the trailer today
because I'm like I gotta see bugs [ __ ]
Trinity it looks good
and it's the same producers as Mandy
okay it looks pretty cool actually and I
was like I'm kind of excited and he's
his best movie if you ask me I was gonna
say I think it is - well I mean he was
in some good [ __ ] well okay I think
raising Arizona's didn't I get that on
blu-ray
no that's what I got man I think raising
Arizona is his best movie but Mandy is
up there for sure you've never seen
rising Arizona have you yeah the guy
okay I think that might be and he was no
valley girl - you guys girl but yeah I
think I saw it but yeah so nowadays like
I said they say the the mansion's
haunted like I said there's some good
hunter shows it's nothing like horribly
egregious like nobody says those demons
or anything like that but like people
that have lived there like reported
hearing like you know footsteps are like
seeing an apparition of a little girl or
like the doors opening and closing I
think that was even interestingly I
heard that there was even an account of
an apparition from way back in like 1888
or something like that like with like
way late in the 19th century because
like I said the house was you know it
was stripped like from the mob and
everything like that I think it was
abandoned for a time but then it was
later renovated and then other people
started moving on for a while it was
like a school it's been like it's been a
bunch of different things you know what
I mean like a conservatory like a music
conservatory it was all different kind
of stuff and like I said it's a private
residence now but um I think back in the
late 19th century a family that lived
there the guy ported that he got up in
the middle of the night one night and
went in to check on their baby and he
saw a woman standing by the baby's
cradle and he thought it was his wife
and he was like oh hey you know you're
over there by the baby or whatever and
then he goes back into the bedroom but
his wife was still in bed so you know
there was that whole thing so I don't
know how true that is but that was an
account like from way back when but yeah
so as I said if your endeavor in New
Orleans you might want to go check it
out can't go inside but you can walk by
it doesn't really look like a mansion it
kind of looks like a I don't know it
looks like a bank sort of to me it's not
very it's not very pretty and apparently
like oh what a lot of people say because
if you look at the pictures of the
building
there's one window like on the the back
end that still looks like it's like
concreted or bricked over and so I think
the legend does arose it's like a word
that's where that girl jumped out even
though
the story she was supposed to fallen off
the roof not out of the window yeah but
I don't know why that window is bricked
up but that's what that's what the
stories is like oh that's or that what
girl fell out that's why it's all
bricked up still like goo creepy but
yeah I've seen a couple one say that all
right so we probably gone long enough
about Delphine LaLaurie so hope you guys
yeah [ __ ] happy yeah like I said she
was a horrible person that's like you
know what I mean even if all the other
[ __ ] about her is a true the [ __ ] she
did it was bad enough yeah I know I
think what really happened was is she
started she got married to that third
guy her income was [ __ ] up he was
spending a lot of her money she started
to go broke I don't think she could
really feed all these slaves as she had
a lot of them ran some of them started
to [ __ ] lip off and she was using
that Foreman to [ __ ] punish the ones
and try to keep him under control
yeah but it started to fall apart and I
think psychologically she was [ __ ] up
she was ordering them to be tied up and
lashed and [ __ ] and [ __ ] leaving them
up there for [ __ ] months at a time
but you know they caught her they fell
they didn't catch her she got away done
I meant they caught doing they caught I
mean like yeah I caught her doing this
[ __ ] so then they brought them all out
if we showed the public of the [ __ ]
neglect and the abuse and she skipped
town yeah I kind of yes probably what
happened and like I said they're no
one's really quite sure what happened to
her they she probably died in France
either in 1842 or 18-49 one of my
favorite stories is that she died by
being gouged by a boar during a boar
hunt I think she died in obscurity she
lost all her money that's what I think
maybe like I said I don't I'm just gonna
go with the normal [ __ ] tempo of life
the way it happens I don't think she
made a comeback she'd have been too old
yeah because there have been some
stories that she came back to New
Orleans like under an assumed name cuz
she know because in letters they do have
letters from her that she wrote to her
relatives where she said she wanted to
come back to New Orleans and they think
that maybe that's why that grave plaque
is there in New Orleans like maybe after
she died in France because they're
pretty sure she died in France that they
sent her body back there because she had
always wanted to go back to New Orleans
and her kids told her not I don't think
that's a good idea
because like I said they still have
letters from her kids to where they're
just saying I don't think you should
come back here because some of our kids
still lived in it I might have been a
descent
though that might have been that mama
the gravestone of a descendant or no it
was her it was her name it had her it
had her maiden name on it and everything
you dig it up and see if there was a
body there though yeah I'm not sure but
like I said like I said it's it's
possible that she that her body could
have been shipped back like her family
could have had her body shipped back
because they knew she wanted to come
back and that's true but they thought
that it was the rest of her family still
making money um I'm not really sure like
I said I think her relatives like and
some of her kids still lived in that
area could have been that they made
enough money to send back to France to
keep her and [ __ ] relative calm and
it did seem like from the I'm the
snippets I've read of the letters I mean
she kept saying you know I really want
to come back to New Orleans and her kids
kept saying yeah don't don't do that
because apparently there was even from
you know that time there was still like
her name was mud pretty much yeah and
they just thought it would be a bad idea
for her to come back because like some
mob my [ __ ] ear I stayed over there
for a while and I think she died over
there elet of Comfort gun got sick and
died because people didn't live that
long then they brought the body back and
turned her there with the rest of the
family something like that yeah I think
she died let's see like I said she was
born in 1775 and she either died at 1842
or 18-49 yeah back in those days a woman
really couldn't get really wealthy
unless she married well yeah I mean and
she was too old to remarry a real choice
husband at that time she I don't know
whatever I'm gonna ever ended up
happening to her husband though I never
see anything sounds like he ran out on
her I mean I don't know if he ran out on
her or if he went with them to France
because he as far as I know he kind of
vanished from the records too so well
she might have he might have gone into
exile as that means he wasn't her Edmund
he wasn't really making a name for
himself so that was he he was down there
probably not even if he was with her he
wasn't making a lot of money yeah yeah I
mean probably you know and like I said I
think there might have been that might
have been going on and like I said he
might have been like um he's probably
living a middle-class lifestyle they
were probably living a middle-class
lifestyle in probably lower middle class
maybe they just think in France because
you see it did in the south really you
could live a lot better on a lot less
money then yeah good Europe during that
yeah uh just that's just the way it was
yeah you know you had people from the
middle class coming from coming from
Europe and moving to the moving to the
south and eating learners all the time
they'd they lived a lot better yeah with
their money you know their competition
was lesser the population density was
you know yeah that's a fraction of what
France was during those days yeah so you
know then you know make it big yeah like
I said we'll probably never know and I
don't think it much came of her probably
not well like I said she kind of it
seems like she just went into exile yeah
you know in France yeah like I for sure
she probably died in France yeah you
know I think that I'd hold that's what
the rat hole slave incident is a sign of
if you ask me financial and mental
collapse yeah well like I said there
might have been a thing to about her
husband not only maybe taking all her
money but also maybe kind of like
[ __ ] around with the slaves and may
be mad about that because like I said he
was like half her age almost you have
these are male slaves up there being
punished I think that I think they were
well some of them were female too and
actually a lot of female slaves
quote-unquote disappeared from the
records like during their time when they
were so I don't know she might have
killed more people than they thought up
like I said she might have been doing
that chaining him up in the Attic for a
long time and then just when they died
like rotating him out you know what I
mean but this is she might have done
that a bunch more time the mitigating
circumstance is also that slaves ran a
lot and you know that means yeah I mean
some of them might have escaped I hope
they did laughs a Priok sake during that
collapse a lot of them probably escaped
in Albert I would have sent I would
think that would be easier for a for a
female slave to escape than a male slave
yeah because it'd be easier for her to
pilot a fight a fine place to go yeah
that's true Sonne protector yeah alright
so that will do it for our episode on
Delphine LaLaurie hope you guys enjoyed
it that was episode 169 and remember if
you like the show like share subscribe
on all your social media share with all
your friends and family it really does
help us out a lot if you would like to
financially support the show with even
as little as a dollar or two dollars a
month would really help us a lot you can
go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
we have a blog 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com
and there is a little button in the
sidebar where you go to a PayPal account
if you'd like to give a one-time
donation and that will do it for episode
169 we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]